hello everyone thank you for being here
I guess I should start by introducing
myself I know II called it a good job
but I should at least pronounce my last
name correctly so my name is Sara Sweden
this is how it's pronounced
I come from Lebanon all over in the
Middle East there isn't really much to
say about me anyway
I'm just a freelance front-end developer
I love CSS I love teaching I love
writing and so I've combined both into
writing tutorials and articles most of
which have been about CSS like CSS
regions yes shapes a lot maybe some of
you know some of my articles I've
written two for Alastair part recently
and I also write them where I write them
on my blog obviously my very simple blog
I also write for code drops where I'm an
author a team member as well and that's
pretty much it there is a really
something else to say I guess I should
also add that this is my first
conference talk ever
thank you so I'm really excited to be
here really nervous and yeah I guess I
should just remember to breathe it's
really really awesome you know what's
really great about this is I finally
have the chance to talk to someone or to
a bunch of people about something that I
wrote that I do and that I'd really like
and they're going to be to actually
understand every single word I say
yeah I'm sure most of you if not all of
you have been through it talking to
someone with an op tech savvy about Web
Design and alike and sometimes they're
like and then just move away it happened
it actually happened so it's really
great to be here on the subject of
understanding every word I'm going to
say I think I should give you a heads up
we as Lebanese tend to use certain words
that have no equivalent in English and
one of these words is the word and no
I'm giving you a heads up because it
just
happens sometimes involuntarily and if I
do say one of these two words I'm going
to mention you can either ignore them or
just know their meaning the first word
is end no it actually has no meaning
candle we just put it in there and the
sentences and it's mostly used in the
context when you're saying something an
idea and you want to elaborate on that
idea and you don't know how to do it so
you just or you do do it but in order to
okay the way to connect the idea to its
explanation you just throw an endo and
and in between now you may not realize
it you might not you may not notice it
but if you do in order so just know that
I'm going to be elaborating on something
and explaining more another word is best
best is the Lebanese word for but but
with a single T not - okay yeah
so if I do say bus just translate to but
and you should be fine as long as it's
well but okay so I'm here to talk to you
today about styling and animating
scalable vector graphics with CSS and
now scalable vector graphics as defined
in Wikipedia are an xml-based vector
image format for two-dimensional
graphics with support for interactivity
and animation they are basically just
tags that render images and these images
have support for interactivity and
animations
now the interactivity and animations can
be added using javascript maybe using
some back-end language I'm not sure
because I'm I'm I totally start with
back-end stuff and you can also add it
using using CSS and that's the part that
I'm interested in for this talk and just
like many talks about s videos I should
go over why s videos are really awesome
because they really are SVG's are
accessible they are accessible to screen
readers if you make them accessible I
have a slide about this at the end of
the talk they're accessible in a sense
that they have a very accessible Dom API
and they're accessible to us developers
through the inspector or the web the dev
tools of whatever favorite browser
you're using you can inspect SVG nodes
just like you would expect HTML elements
they have very good browser supports
starting ie9 for most of the SVG
features and all modern browsers
because SPG's are basically text they
can be gzipped and therefore have
smaller file sizes vendor PNG and JPEG
counterparts they have built-in graphics
effects like blend modes filters
clipping and masking among others so
basically just Photoshop in the browser
which is awesome
they are interactive installable part
that I'm going to be focusing on and
they have tools there are tools for
creating SPG's animating SVG is
manipulating SPG's optimizing SPG's
three of the most popular tools for
create creating them are Adobe
Illustrator which works in all four all
platforms but it's not free a very
decent and fairly popular alternative is
Inkscape and sketch is also an
alternative from what I hear is really
good but it's Mac OSX only so if you're
stuck on Windows like me you're not
going to be using that so no matter what
SVG editor you use none of them exports
really optimized and clean code most of
the code that is exported usually
contains editor metadata comments empty
groups and empty elements and stuff like
that and basically just a bunch of junk
that you can remove safely without
affecting the rendering of the SVG so
it's usually so it's generally a good
idea to use a third-party stand-alone
optimizing to to optimize the code for
you because you know before I'm talking
about this because before you want to
start actually styling and animating as
we do you want to have something clean
to work with so there are many tools out
there to optimize SVG's I'm going to
mention two of them one of them is the
SVG editor by Peter calling bridge it's
an online tool it allows you to either
important SVG file or just copy/paste it
it offers a lot of options that allow
you to optimize your spgs and clean up
the code and what's really nice about it
is that whenever you check an option an
optimization option you get to see the
result of applying that application to
that optimization to the SVG directly
live in front of you so it helps you
make better choices on what
optimizations to make and what not to it
can help
slash your file size by a lot for
example this very simple path that I've
that I've optimized the original file
size is highlighted
one point one kilobyte it's very small
file but it was slashed down to 0.6
kilobytes so optimizing your SVG code
code is a really good idea if you don't
want to use an online tool you can use
this SVG Oh SVG o stands for SVG
optimizer it's a node.js based tool with
with a very simple and nice actually
very simple API dragon no not API a very
simple drag-and-drop GUI so if you're
not going to if you don't want to use an
online tool you can use this one it's
really nice this is a very quick example
I think yeah it's the same path that I
showed in this slide I exported it from
s from Adobe Illustrator now Adobe
Illustrator gives us a lot of options to
optimize and customize the code and
clean it up kind of clean it up but even
after cleaning it up and Adobe
Illustrator I I was left with the code
on the left and after optimizing it and
Peters tool you can see how much the
file size is a lot smaller a lot cleaner
more readable in general now after
you're done with you know optimizing the
code you're probably going to want to
clean up a little bit more some manual
stuff and give classes to your to your
selectors or elements if you're
exporting the code from from Adobe
Illustrator and you're separating the
styles from from the mark-up in SPG you
can add styles to an to SVG in different
ways I'm going to go over them in a
minute but when the styles are separated
you have well inside the stylesheet
you're going to have to set a selected
target and SVG element and of course
you're going to use ID selectors class
selectors etc the generic names produced
by Adobe Illustrator or any other SVG
editors usually look like this st 0 st 1
SC 2 they make no sense whatsoever so
you're going to want to change the class
names and do more semantic ones so now
that we have some clean code to work
with it's time to talk about adding
styles to SPG's now the dividing line
between HTML and CSS is clear
HTML cares for content and structure and
CSS cares for the looks however an SVG
the line is blurred to say the least and
SVG is an image that is marked up and
that has tiles so things are just mixed
up into one thing you see SVG 1.1 did
not require any CSS and therefore it was
necessary to present the styles using
what is known as SVG presentation
attributes presentation attributes
basically provide a shorthand way for
applying a CSS property to an SVG node
in the form of an attribute for example
you have this fill stroke stroke with
among many others you can set the
opacity like this as an attribute
transforms apply transforms etc now a
subset of all these present SVG
presentation attributes can be set using
CSS however not all of them can be set
for example you cannot if you have an
SVG node inside an SVG file and you want
to change its height and width you
cannot do that via CSS you're still
going to use presentation attributes for
width and height but a subset of all SVG
attributes can be set using CSS some of
these are shared with CSS there are CSS
properties equivalent to the
presentation attributes and there are
loops sorry and there are some
presentation attributes that are SVG
only the table shows a list of all
presentation attributes that can be
represented and applied using CSS as CSS
properties now because many of the
presentation attributes are implemented
as CSS properties you can set them using
either inline Styles just like you would
any other CSS property using document
Styles embedded or using external style
sheets if you're going to embed them
using inline Styles it's going to be
inside a style attribute so instead of
using the full stroke and stroke width
as presentation attributes in this
example I've used them as CSS properties
inside the style attribute you can also
use style tags inside an SVG document
and that the styles and the styles will
be just like normal CSS there's a
selector there's a style and you just
apply it now and note about the C data
block that you can see that you see here
it's not always recommended but because
some of the
selectors and CSS like a child's like
the children selector which is an arrow
or a chevron I don't know if it's the
correct thing to say yeah so that arrow
can well it could basically cause
problems with the XML parser okay so
sometimes it's recommended that you use
it but you don't always have to use it
if you if you optimize the code using
using Peters SVG editor it's it's
automatically removed so you don't
always need it you can also embed the
Styles inside a style tag outside the
SVG in an html5 or XHTML document as you
see here this example and you can use
last but not least an external
stylesheet if you have an SVG document
and you're going to import an SVG
stylesheet you're going to have to use
the XML stylesheet element or attack to
do that style Cascades now because
because SVG presentation attributes are
implemented as CSS properties they do
contribute to the style cascade and CSS
but presentation attributes count as
low-level author style sheets and are
overridden by any other style definition
external style sheets document style
sheets are inline Styles the example
here the circle I've used the fill
attribute with the value blue to give it
a blue background and then I've used it
as a CSS property inside the style
attribute and the the pink color inside
the style attribute overrides the blue
one outside the diagram on the right
shows the order of the styles and the
Cascade styles lower in the diagram
override those above them and you can
see that presentation attributes are up
above the only stylesheet that does not
override presentation attributes is the
user agent style sheets okay now inside
any style sheet it just a note about the
talk I'm going to be focusing about
concepts and stuff you should know or
would want to know if you're going to
apply styles and animate animate SVG's
you're not going to see any really
impressive demos or effects so inside
the style rules rules
okay the selectors that you can use in
CSV
not all CSS selectors can be used to
select SVG elements this is really
important because I've tried using for
example the direct at the direct the
direct sibling selector to select an
element in SVG it didn't work I tried
adding just for demonstration purposes
while I was preparing the slides I tried
using the before-and-after studio
elements to add generated content it
doesn't work so these and these
selectors and the slides all of them
work maybe possibly some extra selectors
could be added later however if you want
to know more details you can always
visit the specification the link at the
end of the slide links is goes to the
specification now a very simple example
I got from the iconic icon set it just
shows you that you can style an SVG and
apply a transition to its to its
properties just like you would with a
CSS applied to an HTML element in this
example the light bulb is made up of
grey dashes or strokes or paths and when
they are hovered the stroke width
increases the color increases the stroke
color and not increase the color does
not increase the color changes and the
background color fades in giving it an
effect of lighting you know getting lit
so and you can see how in the dev tools
you can inspect every single line of
these lines of the light bulb and down
at the bottom I've highlighted the
before and on hover Styles you change
you change them just like you would
change any other CSS property now
embedding SVG's there are different ways
to embed in SVG and in a document and
this is relevant to the subject of this
talk because the technique that you use
to embed your SVG determines whether or
not this any external Styles
interactivity and style ability will be
applied to this video or not depending
on the technique some of the stuff that
you apply may not work and you may get a
headache trying to forget out if you
don't already know that I know I did so
there are different ways to embed an SVG
the first one is using an image tag just
like you would use any image using an
image tag you can do that with SVG as
well for security reasons many
browsers are going to be to disable
external styles interactivity and
scripting on an SVG when it is embedded
using an image tag the same thing
applies to the sixth one I should have
reordered these by the way but it's okay
I kind of like jumping back and down up
and down so this the when you're when
using an SVG as a background image using
CSS which is number six at bottom the
same thing applies just like with an
image tag no external styles will be
applied no interactivity no CSS
animations you can also embed an SVG
inline that's number five inline using
an SVG tag I think this is one of the
most popular ways to that we're using
today SVG the SVG tag using an iframe
and using an embed tag and using an
object tag which means that two three
four and five are going to preserve
style ability interactivity and CSS
animations now the most the most
suitable of all these four techniques I
wouldn't say the most suitable but the
SVG inline embedding SVG inline is
really nice if you're willing to drop
some backwards compatibility the the
iframe is okay but if you use an iframe
then controlling your SVG from the main
page where you're aware you're embedding
it is going to be a little hard the
embed tag has never been part of any
specification so but it's wyman
supported because it's used for
embedding some some kind of content that
rely on it on a plugin like a dope like
Adobe Flash and the object tag the
object tag is is one of my favorites it
is my favorite because it allows you to
provide a fallback image between the
opening and the closing object tag so if
the if your SVG image cannot be rendered
for any reason the browser is just going
to render the fallback in between okay
so this table shows just which the
techniques and whether or not each one
supports or preserves links external
Styles interactivity and CSS animations
there is a note here that if you're
going to use an image to embed an SVG
the CSS animations applied are not going
to work however if you use SVG
animations they are going to be
preserved
so I have an example here a very simple
example it's bear CSS with SVG it's
basically a bear with a fish in his hand
very happy it's going to be eating it so
I've added an animation just to animate
the fish a little it's trying to it's
not it's trying to you know get away
because no one likes to be eaten by a
bear of course so I've added the
animations in the first example using
CSS animations and then I embedded it as
an image the one on the left and I've
used the one on the right embedding it
as an object tag the CSS animations are
not preserved on the Left they are
preserved on the right and I've added a
hover interaction to the image the
helper interaction is preserved if
you're using an object tag and it is not
preserved if unity if you're using an
image okay
then I've recreated the same example but
instead of applying instead of using a
CSS animation to animate the fish I use
the anim transform element which is an
SVG animation and then I embedded is
that embedded it as an image again here
on the left the SVG animation is
preserved but any other interactions on
hover are not preserved so this example
the takeaway here is that CSS animations
are not going to be preserved if you use
an image tag but SVG animations will be
preserved but without any interactions
next up responsive fine SVG s now SVG is
usually when you export them from an SVG
editor and SVG has a height and a width
and any element it would be at HTML or
SVG or whatever if you specify a height
and width it's not fluid anymore so
featuring this section is a really nice
owl it's a very happy owl I'm not a cat
person so you won't be seeing any cats
in my presentation sorry about that
yeah so I have this SVG of an owl when I
exported it it had a width and a height
so the first step to special
responsibility and the height and to add
the view box if you don't already have
it the view box is very important
because the next step you're going to
want to preserve the aspect ratio of the
SVG as you as you resize it as as it
shrinks or expands you want the aspect
ratio to be preserved however without
the view box attribute the preserve
aspect ratio has no effect so you need
to have both now the preserve aspect
ratio can take one of many values and
the value that you're most likely going
to be using is the x-men why men with
the keyword meat basically what this
value means is that the browser is going
to resize the image while preserving the
aspect ratio expanding it enough so that
the entire view box of the SVG is
visible within the viewport and it's
going to be expanding it as much as
possible while while preserving the
other two options are no restrictions
okay after okay now that we've said all
the SVG attributes remove the ones that
we don't need and other the ones that we
do need we're going to embed and drop it
in a container now because this is just
a wrapper and no it doesn't it doesn't
really have any semantics we were
probably going to be using a div I've
given it a class of my SVG containers
now SVG's as I mentioned before can be
embedded as object image or inline SVG
the technique this technique is
responsive fiying technique by the
responsive I should totally be a word
yeah yeah I mean if selfie got into the
generate then yeah so you can use any
embedding technique and this is still
going to work okay so after you've
wrapped it in a container you're going
to apply the padding hack on the
container now how many of you are
familiar with the padding hack oh not
not a lot okay so basically the padding
hack allows you to give an element's a
width and a height it is a hack however
you're going to see that it is a like
really hack it's not a technique that
well we should have a standard way in
CSS that the idea behind it is to give
the element a height and the width while
preserving a specific ratio of the
height to the width now the way this
works is the height is given the element
is given a height zero because we want
to be able to give it a height that is
risk that is relative to the to the
width the first so first we're going to
give it a height zero we're going to
position two giving it to give it two to
give
it a position relative this is going to
create a positioning context for the SVG
we're going to talk about the snacks now
the width can be anything you want
depending on where you want to put it on
the page you want to give you want to
give it a full width half worth whatever
the width is anything you want and the
padding top is the SVG height the one
that we removed before over the SVG
width time the times the width value of
the container that you can set to
whatever value you want now the reason
behind using padding top to expand the
element is that the padding top is set
relative to the when you're using a
percentage value to specify the padding
the top and the bottom padding the
percentage is set relative to the width
of the element not relative to the
height so when you're specifying a
padding beat a top padding or a bottom
padding or a bottom bottom padding using
percentages that padding and that height
that we're going to get is going to be
relative to the width and so you're
going to be able to maintain a specific
ratio now the idea is to give the SVG
container a ratio of high to its that
that is the same as the ratio of height
and width to of the SVG oh my god I'm
totally ok so in this for my example for
owl that SVG the padding top is 300 over
300 because the height and width are
both 300 times 100 which is the width
I've given it I've given it a full width
and you get a 100% padding top however
if the width of the container is for
example 60% if you don't want to give it
if you don't want to expand it to the
entire width of its container the
padding top is going to be 300 over 300
times 60 which gives us 60%
now if the owl now in this case it just
happens that the out the owl image is a
perfect square height equal width but if
they are not equal for example if it has
a 250 width and a height of 400 pixels
the padding top would be calculated by
dividing 400 by 250 times 100 and that
would be 160 percent it's all just
basically it's basically just math you
use the padding hack and give
values depending on the height on the
width of the SVG that's just it's very
simple and then you position the SVG
inside the container we've given the
container a position:relative because
well the height has been collapsed the
container has been collapsed and we've
given it a padding so the sqg is not
going to be and where you expect it to
be it's going to be pushed down by the
amount of padding that you've given the
container so in order to push it up
again you give it you use an absolute
value no you use position absolute and
just put it at the top left corner of
the element now with 100% of for the SVG
is only required if you're you if you're
embedding it using an image tag so it's
basically just math and then a padding
hat and then you just resize this is my
favorite part
I do this for almost every website that
I visit I have to resize that that's the
first thing that I do yeah it's really
fun
so animating SVG's with CSS now that we
know how to style as VG's how to add the
styles and how to embed them we're going
to you're going to choose if you're
going to apply CSS animations you're
going to choose as CSS an embedding
technique that allows you to preserve
these animations now most of our
animations like the real impressive ones
are going to have some kind of
transforming transformations and it's so
SP SPG's respond to the transform and
transform origin properties just kind of
just like an HTML element would would do
but there are some vertical differences
first to be the first one is that the
transform origin on an HTML element and
an SVG an SVG element is different if
you have an HTML element it has a box
model so it has a padding margin it has
a box model by babban but an SVG does
not so that transform origin the default
value for the transform origin on an
HTML on an HTML element is 50% by 50%
which is the center of the element which
is what you'd normally expect however if
you have an SVG element like a circle or
a rectangle the transform origin is set
to 0 0 it's used 0 0 is the top-left
corner not of the
itself but of the SVG canvas of the
entire SVG canvas so if you're going to
rotate an element this is most this is
usually obvious the transform origin is
mostly obvious when you're rotating an
element so if you had a div and HTML
element and you have an SVG rectangle
and you rotate apply a transformation
rotate it by 45 degrees the HTML element
is going to be rotated around its center
but the SVG element rectangle is going
to be rotated around the top left corner
of the SVG canvas so in most cases you
will want to change the transform origin
of an SVG element and place it at the
center of the element you'd think that
this is very simple but it's not
first of all setting the transform
origin on SVG well it is simple in a
sense technically it is simple but
because we're now living in a perfect
web world and because of all the bugs
that we get that's well it sucks it
basically sucks so you can set it
transform origin on SVG elements using
percentage values or using absolute
length values like pixels for example if
you set them using percentage values the
value is set relative to the elements
bounding box which includes the stroke
used to draw its border if you're using
absolute length values the origin is set
relative to the SVG canvas pretty simple
now so if we're going to if you if we go
go back to the same example we have a
div and HTML element and a rectangle in
SVG and we set the transform origin to
50% but by 50% 50% on the rectangle and
side the SVG it is rotated around its
own center okay because we're using
percentage values heads-up this is the
first part transform origin issue and
Firefox basically setting the transform
origin and percentages and Firefox on an
SVG element does not work it is a bug it
has been filed it should not be a
problem if you're not rotating anything
but it will be a problem if you are so
you will want to currently at the time
being just use absolute values to set
the the transform origin on an SVG
element this is a very simple example a
pinwheel I don't look at it too much I
don't want you getting dizzy on me so in
order to write two rows
it I use a percentage value for a chrome
or for WebKit to set the transform
origin and I've used absolute values to
set the transform origin and to make it
work in Firefox okay so this looks
simple just use percentage values and
absolute values for Firefox however five
days ago when I was working on the
slides and I was preparing this demo I
was zooming in and out I was doing out
because I wanted to take a smaller
screen recording to add to this slide
and as I started zooming out I got this
the element is not transforming around
its own center anymore in chrome if
you're using transform origin and chrome
with percentage values which do work
try not to zoom the page in and out
because it's going to mess everything up
yeah this is also a bug I talked to jerk
shoulder from Adobe and he filed a bug
he said that it should be fairly simple
to solve and that it may may be solved
fixed not sold fixed before my
presentation but I think it didn't so
yeah zooming in and out in WebKit blank
does not maintain the transform origin
at the center of the rotating element
and it's a book and Firefox it does not
happen because you're using absolute
values and the the transform origin is
set relative to the entire canvas
zooming in and out causes no problems at
at all so for the time being just use
absolute values till all the bugs have
been fixed
another heads up is hardware
acceleration and chrome when you're
applying CSS 3d transformations to an
HTML element they are automatically
hardware accelerated and Chrome however
if you're applying these transformations
to an SVG element they're not just that
in chrome they are not Firefox does
apply some kind of hardware acceleration
for transformation CSS transformations
on SVG elements but and chrome it
they're not hardware accelerated so if
you do see some a world you know
flickering and all that it's it's normal
just they're not hardware accelerated my
last section animating SVG paths I can't
believe I made it this far no honestly
okay so animating SVG paths there are
different effects that you can create if
you're going to any to animate SVG paths
actually SVG paths are one of the most
powerful features of SVG you can create
some really impressive effects by
animating them one of the most popular
recently effect is by creating an
animated line drawing using using CSS
now you can do it and CSS but in order
to animate an SVG path as if it were
drawing you know as if you were drawing
itself has have many of you seen the X
Box I think it was the X Box website I'm
not sure just ignore it okay to animate
an SVG path and a Kathak like draw
itself you need to know its exact length
if you know its exact length it becomes
very simple you just set the stroke -
array and - offset to the path length
which you know already apply transition
and for and then on hover or click or
whatever you just set this stroke -
offset to zero and the line is going to
animate itself it's going to start with
no line and then it's going to be
animated as if it as if you're actually
drawing it this is a very simple example
now in this case I downloaded this SVG I
just started trying different values
because I didn't want to use JavaScript
to animate it so I just started drawing
different values and it turned out that
the value 4000 was enough so I just
applied it the stroke - array and -
offset I gave them the 4000 value added
a transition and on hover the cities
just lit up and then the the lamp is
animated the full color of the inner
lamp changes and I've added a gradient
which transitions animates very smoothly
of course the light lighting the lamp up
happens after the line animation where a
finishes so there is a transition delay
applied and the
and a lamp animation transition is and
six seconds oh yeah six seconds so I've
waited till the animation of the line
was finished and then I've lit the lamp
up well like I said there isn't really
any impressive demos here however there
is one impressive demo I found online
which is this one I found it on the GD
studio it's I think it's a French studio
the really nice thing about it is the
the flame is first turned off you click
it and then an image and animation
starts now you can recreate this
animation using CSS if you know if you
know all of the length and you just play
with the values of the delays and it's
really it's very possible yeah so the
animation is very slow on PowerPoint I
think yeah it's an issue with the
PowerPoint okay now in most cases if you
want to create an animated line drawing
effect you may not know the length that
the absolute length of the path so you
will want to retrieve it using
javascript there is there is a method in
JavaScript to retrieve the path length
it is path dot get total it is get total
path get total length okay that's the
method and then you just use JavaScript
to set this tractor or - array and -
offset just like we did earlier so the
whole idea is just to know the path
length and then that set the stroke -
array and - offset to that length and
animated okay so if you want to know
more about these techniques about the
how-tos and how it works yeah I suggest
that you read this article by Jake
Archibald it's a really excellent one
you it has an interactive demo in it and
it's very very simple you just recommend
you read it if you want to know more
about this now another way to animate
SVG paths is by morphing paths where you
start with the one shape and you finish
with another now you don't need to know
any path lengths in this case you just
need to know the starting shape and the
finishing shape and you just animate
them however this is
possible in CSS there is no way n CSS
that you can specify a beginning part
and finishing path and possibly even
intermediate intermediate parts too and
then animate them there is no way I
think there should be a way so I hope
that someday we get a way to do that
this this effect that you can see is the
Mac OSX uni effector created by Manuela
from code drops it's one of my favorite
SVG path animation effects it's really
great so you see you start with an arrow
shape and then it morphs into a full
width just rectangle so yeah the idea is
to create an SVG path with one part to
morph and to morph it into another one
you only the first path the second path
and possibly intermediate paths if you
want your animation to go through
specific shapes in between and there is
no way and CSS to an image one SVG path
into another at the time being okay so
in order to do that if you want to be
able to manipulate SVG paths I recommend
you use this snap SVG library it's very
it's awesome at the website describes it
as being it makes dealing with SVG nodes
as easy as jQuery makes manipulating the
Dom easy okay
and now animated SVG's can be used as
gif replacement this is one of my
favorite things I this code this code
nut code this code I found it on the oak
website the oak studio and in this
article the link to the article is at
the bottom the writer says that by using
animated SVG's instead of gif s we were
able to reduce our page size from 1.6
megabytes to 389 kilobytes and reduce
our page load time from 8.75 seconds to
412 milliseconds that's a huge
difference it's it's really great so if
you ever can use SVG s for simple
animations instead of using a gif then
by all means go for it and before I
finish my talk it's really important not
to forget don't forget to make SVG is
accessible SVG's are images and every
any kind of content that you're going to
use in web page you have to make it
accessible if you can do it
one of the best articles my favorite SVG
articles is this article by Leonie
Watson written for the side point
website
it's about tips for creating accessible
SVG it's a must read seriously if you're
going to work with SVG you have to read
this article lots of great information
you just have to read it okay and
another thing is don't forget to
optimize and degrade gracefully provide
fallbacks now SVG the slides here by
Todd Parker of the filament group are
one of the best slides about SVG I've
ever seen
they contain a complete workflow from
starting with tips and tricks for
creating SPG's and different SVG editors
to exporting them also tips and tricks
and providing fallback tools for
automating fallbacks it's really awesome
if you are going to dig into SVG anytime
soon I recommend you do read these
slides they're excellent and last but
not least if you need to know any about
any browser support for SVG feature just
raise it can I use comm and look the
feature up and thank you very much
you